parler on va faire une interview oui non
et vous ne répondrez amanda lear que par
oui ou par non
c'est bouger brigade à morlaàs sergent
peut rallumer désolé ok on allume heures
désolé on va faire une interview
oui non on est pour
bien amanda lear si vous trompiez votre
jules est ce que vous lui diriez non est
ce que vous croyez en dieu
oui est-ce que vous donnez dans la rue à
ceux qui font la manche
oui est ce qu'il ya des trucs que vous
refusez de fer au lit oui quoi je me
suis bien j'ai moi même je suis auto
piégée oh là là j'aimerais savoir qu'il
ya des trucs dégoûtant brawn on a mûri à
dessein à la manga est ce qu on dit à
chaque fois m en s'embrassant sur la
bouche et que l'on décrit comme ça il ya
des trucs comme l'argent aime faire et
moi par particulière pourquoi exemple la
vaisselle c'est très coûteux a des poils
plein les dents après à allez vous
réaliser vos rêves d'enfants n'ont quand
même pas fait le plus gros la république
ça qui aspire à devenir pas cogiter sur
tu voudrais être président un jour non
amanda est ce que vous avez déjà eu des
expériences diensten sexe vous
rencontrez quelqu'un vous rencontrez
quelqu'un environ une demi-heure après
c'est dans les chiottes du restaurant
wind héniart d'accord bras
c'est assez rare et un thé un raptus
dans l'ascenseur ça vous êtes arrivé
déjà tarn et tarn et aimeriez vous
devenir amanda lear la maîtresse d'un
chef d'état oui avis aux amateurs aj le
pouvoir que tard c'est toi qui dirige
parce que tout ce que tu lui un mandat
avez vous déjà connu la dépendance
sexuelle
oui non mais c'est quelque chose de
terrible
ce week en dix mecs gelé dans la peau à
la dea qui me touche ça pose à sa bouche
et tous et c'est dramatique
est ce que vous croyez avant de dire
qu'il ya quelque chose après la mort oui
des compositions vous avez déjà fait
l'amour à 5 à 5
non c'est beaucoup 500 faire des
soustractions attend 1,5 de masina
taille du lit au akkar non à 3,1 temps à
aa
car oui ah oui 4 oui oui oui oui il y
avait des femmes non les animaux
amanda lear avec vous plus de qualités
que de défauts non oui y at il un
fantasme que vous n'avez pas réalisé
oui ma fille en même temps mais en même
temps c'est vrai il faut il faut de
toute façon qu'est toujours un fantasme
non réalisés quand on a réalisé tous ses
fantasmes d'abord on a plus que des bons
souvenirs des fantasmes et puis la vie
est triste faut toujours espérer encore
de faire quelque chose
amanda lear est ce que vous vous aimez
non d'accord ça va venir ça va venir je
travaille là dessus avec mon psy ce
cépage et en hiver bosser mais elle a
dit qu'il prenait ses enfants est ce que
vous feriez un film porno pour un
million de francs non 2 millions non non
mais j'y mourrai posé la question il ya
15 ans j'aurais dit oui parce que je
trouve que j'étais encore photographia
alors maintenant que ça vieillit jolie
attend à partir d'un certain âge je
trouve quand même actuellement face au
crayon de francs donnés les familles en
grand nombre mais quand gazechim un
cycle
des 100 millions non je pourrais pas
veillé à rennes
non j'ai pas de la rue allard était
encore mineure